the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
well let's see so before we actually
start reviewing for the test I'm going
to I still have to tell you a few small
things because I promise to say a few
words about what's the difference you
know more precisely what's the
difference between curl being 0 and a
field being a gradient field and why we
had this assumption that a vector field
had to be defined everywhere for a field
with curl zero to actually be
conservative for our test for gradient
fields to be valid so so more about the
validity of greens theorem and things
like that so we've seen the statement of
greens theorem in two forms
both of them have to do with comparing a
line integral along a closed curve to a
double integral over the region inside
and close by the curve so one of them
says the line integral for work done by
a vector field along a closed curve
counterclockwise is equal to the double
integral of a curl of a field above a
enclosed region and the other one says
the total flux out of the region so the
flux for the curve is equal to the
double integral of divergence of a field
in the region so in both cases we need
the vector field to be defined not only
I mean the left hand side makes sense if
a vector field is just defined on the
curve because it's just a line integral
on C we don't care what happens inside
but for the right hand side to make
sense and therefore for the Equality to
make sense we need the vector field to
be defined everywhere
inside the region so I said if there's
you know a point somewhere in here where
my vector field is not defined then it
doesn't work and actually we've seen
that example
oops so
this only works if f and its derivatives
are defined everywhere in the region R
otherwise we're in trouble
okay so we've seen for example that if I
gave you the vector field minus y i plus
XJ over X square plus y squared so
that's the same vector field that was on
that problem set a couple of weeks ago
then well F is not defined at the origin
but it's defined everywhere else and
wherever it's defined its curl is 0
everywhere else
and so
if we have a closed curve in the plane
well there's two situations one is you
know if it does not enclose the origin
then yes we can apply greens theorem and
it will tell us that it's equal to the
double integral in here
of curl F da which will be 0 because
this is 0
however if I have a curve that encloses
the origin let's say this for example
then well I cannot use the same method
because the curl will the vector field
and scale are not defined at the origin
and in fact you know that you know
ignoring the problem and saying well
curl is still 0 everywhere would give
you the wrong answer because we've seen
an example we've seen that along the
unit circle the total work is 2pi not 0
so we can't use green however we can't
use it directly so there's an extended
version of greens theorem fo that tells
you the following thing well it tells me
that even though I can't do things for
just this region enclosed by C prime I
can still do things for the region in
between two different curves ok so let
me show you what I have in mind
so let's say that I have my curve C
Prime where's my yellow choke oh so I
have this curve C Prime and I can't
apply greens theorem to the region
inside it but let's cut out a smaller
thing so let me call that curve so that
we are going to make going clockwise
you'll see why
then I can say well sorry let me change
my mind
structure is not very well prepare
that's because my vitalism strike okay
so okay so let's say we have C Prime and
C prime C double prime both going
counterclockwise then I claim that
greens theorem still applies and tells
me that the line integral along c prime
minus the line integral along c double
prime is equal to the double integral
over the region in between so here now
it's this region with a whole
of poker and well in our case that will
turn out to be 0 because curl is 0 okay
so this doesn't tell us what each of
these two line integrals is but actually
tells us that they are equal to each
other and so by computing one you can
see actually that for this vector field
if you take any curve that goes
counterclockwise around the origin you
will get 2pi no matter what the curve is
so how do you get to this and you know
why is this not like conceptually a new
theorem well just think of you know the
following thing I'm not going to do it
on top of that because it's going to be
messy if I talk to many things but so
here I have my C double prime here I
have C prime let me actually make a slit
that will connect them to each other
like this okay so now if I take C I can
form a single closed curve that will
enclose all of this region well with an
infinitely thin slit here
counterclockwise and so if I go
counterclockwise around this region
basically I go counterclockwise along
the outer curve then I go along the slit
then I go clockwise along the inside
curve then back along the slit and then
I'm done so if I take the line integral
along this big curve consisting of all
these pieces now I can apply greens
theorem to that because it is a usual
counterclockwise curve that goes around
the region where my field is
well-defined see I've eliminated the
origin from the vector and so the total
line integral for this thing
is equal to the integral along c prime
gets the outer one then I need to also
have what I do along the inner side and
the inner side is going to be C double
prime but going backwards because now
I'm going clockwise on C prime so that
I'm going counterclockwise around the
shaded region plus well of course I
would be contributions from the line
integral along this white segment but I
do it twice once each way so they cancel
out so the white segments cancel out
usually you probably shouldn't in your
notes write down white segments because
parties are not white on your paper but
hopefully you get you get the meaning of
what I'm trying to say okay so basically
that tells you you can still play to
explain greens theorem when the region
has holes in it just you have to be
careful and you know somehow subtract
some other curve so that together things
will work out there's a similar thing
with the divergence theorem of course
with you know with flux and double
integral of div F you can apply exactly
the same argument okay so basically you
can apply greens theorem for a region
that has several boundary curves you
just have to be careful that the outer
boundary must go counterclockwise the
inner boundary either goes clockwise or
you put a minus sign
okay and a last cultural note so
definition we say that a region in the
plane so I should say a connected region
in the plane so that means so connected
means it consists of a single piece okay
so connected you know there's a single
piece this is two guys together are not
connected but if I join them then this
is a connected region we say is simply
with it's simply connected if any closed
cabinet case I need to give a name to a
region let's say are any closed curve in
our bounds so if the interior of any
closed curve in R is also contained in
our so concretely what does that mean
that means the region R does not have
any holes inside it okay so maybe I
should draw two pictures to explain what
I mean
so this guy here is simply connected
while this guy here is not simply
connected because if I take this curve
that's a curve inside my region but you
know the ball the piece that it bounced
is not actually entirely contained in my
region and so why is that relevant well
if you know that your vector field is
defined everywhere in a simply connected
region then you don't have to worry
about this question of you know can I
apply greens theorem to the inside you
know it's automatically okay because if
you have a closed curve then the vector
field is I mean if the vector field is
defined on the curve it will also be
defined inside okay so if the domain of
definition of a vector field is defined
and differentiable
is simply connected then we can always
apply when sphere I mean of course
provided that we do it on a curve where
the vector field is defined I mean
otherwise your line integral does not
make sense so there's nothing to compute
but if you have you know so again the
argument would be well if a vector field
is defined on the curve it's also
defined inside so we are happy and see
so the problem with a vector field here
is precisely but its domain of
definition is not simply connected
because there's a hole namely the origin
so so this guy domain of definition
which is plane minus the origin with the
original removed is not simply connected
and so that's why you have this line
integral that makes perfect sense but
you can't apply greens theorem to it so
now what does that mean in particular
well we've seen this criterion that if a
curl if a curl of a vector field is zero
and it's defined in the entire plane
then the vector field is conservative
and it's a gradient field and the
argument to prove that is precisely to
use greens theorem so in fact the
correct
you know the actual optimal statement
you can make is if a vector field is
defined in a simply connected region and
it's curl is 0 then it's a gradient
field so let me just write that down for
you know
so the correct statement I mean the
previous one we've seen is also correct
but this one is somehow better and
closer to what exactly is needed if curl
F is zero and the domain of definition
where F is defined is simply connected
then F is conservative and that means
also it's a gradient field that's the
same thing okay
any questions on this
nope
okay some good news what I've just said
here won't come up on the test on
Thursday okay
still it's stuff that you should be
aware of generally speaking because it
would be useful say on the next week's
problem set and maybe on the final it
would be you know there won't be any
really really complicated things
probably but there might be some you
know you might need to be at least
vaguely aware of this issue of things
being simply connected okay and by the
way I mean this is also like somehow the
starting point of topology which is you
know the branch of math that studies the
shapes of regions so in particular you
can try to distinguish domains in the
plains by looking at whether they are
simply connected or not and what kinds
of features we have in terms of how you
can join points what kinds of curves
exist in them and since that's the bunch
of math in which I work I thought I
should tell you a bit about it okay so
now back to reviewing for the exam so
we're going to when I'm going to
basically list topics and if time
permits I will say a few things about
problems from practice exam 3b
I'm hoping that you have it or your
neighbor has it or you can somehow get
it anyway given time I'm not sure how
much I will say about the problems in
their themselves but okay so the main
thing to know about this exam is how to
set up and evaluate double integrals and
line integrals if you know how to do
these two things then you're in much
better shape than if you don't
and
so
so the first thing we've seen okay so
just to back it down there's two main
objects and it's kind of important to
not confuse them with each other if
there's double integrals of the regions
of some quantity da the other one is
some line integral along a curve of a
vector field F dot d R or F dot NDS
depending on whether it's work or flux
but we are trying to do and so we should
know how to set up these things and how
to evaluate them and roughly speaking in
this one you start by drawing a picture
of the region then deciding which way
you will integrate it could be DX dy dy
DX Rd Rd theta and then you will set up
the bounds carefully by slicing it and
studying how the bounds for the inner
variable depend on the outer variable so
the first topic will be setting up
double integrals and so remember okay so
maybe I should make this more explicit
we want to have a picture of our and
take slices in the chosen way so that we
get an idea rated integral okay so let's
do just a quick example
so if I look at problem 1 on exam 3b it
says well it says to look at the line
integral from 0 to 1 integral from X 2
to X of possibly something but dy DX and
it says let's look at how we would set
this up the other way around like
exchanging x and y so we should get to
something that will be the same integral
DX dy I mean if you have a function of x
and y then it would be the same function
but the first bounds change so how do we
exchange the order of integration well
the only way to do it consistently is to
the whole picture so let's see what does
this mean here it means we integrate
from y equals x to y equals 2x X between
0 & 1 so we should draw a picture the
lower bound for y is y equals x so let's
draw y equals x that seems to be here
and we'll go up to y equals 2x which is
a line also but with bigger slope and
then alright so for each value of x my
region will go from X 2 to X well and I
do this for all values of x that go from
0 to x equals 1 so I stopped at x equals
1 which is here and then my region is
something like this okay so
this point here in case you're wondering
well when x equals one y is 1 and that
point here is 1 2 ok any questions about
that so far
okay so let's somehow that's the first
kill you know when you see an integral
how to figure out what it means how to
hold the region and then there's the
converse scale which is given the region
how to set up the integral for it so if
we want to set it up instead DX dy then
it means we are going to actually look
at the converse question which is for a
given value of y what is the range of
values of X so if we fix Y well where do
we enter the region and where do we
leave it so we seem to enter on this
side and we seem to leave on that side
at least that seems to be true for the
first few values of Y that I chose but
hey if I take a larger value of y then I
will enter on this side and they will
leave on this vertical side not on that
one so I seem to have two different
things going on the place where I enter
my region is always y equals 2x which is
the same as x equals y over 2 so X seems
to always start at Y over 2 but when I
leave could be either x equals y or here
x equals 1 and that depends on the value
of y so in fact I have to break this
into two different integrals I have to
treat separately the case where Y is
between 0 and 1 and between 1 and 2 so
what I do in that case is I just make
two integrals so I say both of them
start at Y over 2 but in the first case
will stop at x equals y in the second
case will stop at x equals 1
okay and now what are the values of Y
for each case where the first case is
when y is between 0 & 1 the second case
is when y is between 1 & 2 which I guess
this picture now is completely
unreadable but hopefully you've been
following what's been going on as you
can see it in the solutions to the
problem and so that's our final answer
okay any questions about how to set up
double integrals in X Y coordinates no
okay who feels comfortable with this
kind of problem okay good I'm happy to
see the vast majority so the bad news is
we have to be able to do it not only in
X Y coordinates but also in polar
coordinates so when you go to polar
coordinates basically all you have to
remember on the side of the integrand is
that X becomes R cosine theta Y becomes
R sine theta and DX dy becomes rdrd
theta in terms of how you slice for your
region well you will be integrating
first over R so that means what you're
doing is you're fixing a value of theta
and for that value of theta you ask
yourself for what range of values of R
am I going to be inside my visual so if
my equation looks like this then for
this value of theta I would go from 0 to
whatever this distance is and of course
I have to find how this distance depends
on theta and then I will find the
extreme values of theta now of course if
the region is really looking like this
when you're not going to do it in polar
coordinates but if it's not you know a
circle or a half circle or things like
that then even if the problem doesn't
tell you do it in polar coordinates you
might want to seriously consider it okay
so that's I mean I'm not going to do it
but problem two and the practice exam is
a good example of do
something in polar coordinates so in
terms of things that we do with polar
with double integrals there's a few
formulas that I'd like you to remember
about you know applications that we've
seen of double integrals so quantities
that we can compute with double
integrals include things like the area
of the region its mass if it has a
density the average value of some
function for example the average value
of the x and y coordinates which we call
the center of mass moments of inertia so
these are just formulas to remember so
for example the area of a region is the
double integral of just da
it helps you 1 da if you want
ventilating the function 1 you have to
remember formulas for mass for the
average value of a function f bar in
particular X bar Y bar which is the
center of mass and the moment of inertia
that philosophy polar moment of inertia
which is moment of inertia about the
origin so that's double integral of x
squared plus y squared density da but
also moments of inertia about the x and
y axis which are given by you know just
taking one of these guys don't worry
about moment of inertia about an
arbitrary line I won't ask you for a
moment of inertia about some weird line
or something like that ok but these you
should know now what if you somehow you
know on the spur of a moment you forget
what's the formula for moment of inertia
well I mean a clicker if you know that
if you have you know
complete blank in your memory there will
still be partial credit for setting up
the bounds and everything else okay so
you know the general will hole where the
exam will be you know if you're stuck in
a calculation or if you're missing a
little piece of a puzzle try to do as
much as you can in particular I'll try
to at least set up the bounds of the
integral
there would be partial credit for that
always so while we added about wormholes
you know how about evaluation you know
about evaluating integrals so once
you've set it up you know you have to
sometimes compute it well first of all
check you know just in case the problem
says set up but do not evaluate then
don't waste your time evaluating it if a
problem says to compute it then you know
you have to compute it so what kinds of
integration techniques you need to know
so you need to know you must know well
how to integrate the usual functions you
know like one over X or X to the N or
exponential sine cosine things like that
so the usual integrals you must know
what I will call easy trigonometry I
don't want to give you a complete list
if you and the more you ask me about
which ones are on the list form I will
add to the list so but you know those
that you know that you should know you
should know those that you think you
shouldn't know you don't have to know
because I will say well of what I will
say soon you should know also
substitution you know how to set u
equals something and then see oh this
becomes u times D U and so you know
substitution method yes what do I mean
by easy to figure matrix well certainly
you should know how to integrate sine
you should know how to integrate cosine
you should be aware of that sine square
plus cosine square simplifies to 1
and you should be aware of general
things like that I would like you to
know maybe the double angle sine 2x and
cosine 2x know what these are and you
know the kinds of easy things you can do
with that also things that you know
involve substitution setting like u
equals sine T or equals cosine T I mean
let me instead you know give an example
of harp thing that you don't need to
know and then I will answer okay so not
needed on Thursday and doesn't mean but
I don't want you to know them I would
love you to know you know every single
integral formula but that shouldn't be a
top priority so you don't need to know
things like how trigonometric ones so
let me give an example okay so if I ask
you to you know do this one then
actually I will give you you know maybe
like I will read find the formula from
the notes or something like that okay so
that one you don't need to know all four
I would know love if you happen to know
it but if you need it it will be given
to you so these kinds of things but you
cannot compute by any easy method and
integration by parts
I believe that I've successfully test
solved all the problems without doing
any single integration by parts again in
general it's something that I would like
you to know but you know if it shouldn't
be a priority for this week okay so you
had a question on inverse trigonometric
functions let's say the most easy ones I
would like you to know the easiest
inverse trig functions but not much okay
okay
so be aware that these functions exist
but it's not a third priority I should
say I mean the more I tell you I don't
need you to know the more you know your
physics and other teachers might
complain that oh these guys don't know
how to integrate so try not to forget
everything but yes no no here I just
mean like for evaluating just a single
variable integral I will get to I will
get to change of variables in Jacobian
soon but I'm thinking of this as a
different topic you know what I mean by
this one is if I'm asking you to
integrate I don't know what's a good
example zero to one T DT of a square
root of 1 plus T squared then you should
think of maybe substituting u equals 1
plus T squared and then it becomes
easier
okay so this kind of trick that's that's
what I have in mind here specifically
and again if you're stuck you know you
know in particular if you hit this
dreaded guy and you don't actually have
a formula giving you what it is it means
one of two things one is something's
wrong with your solution the eruption is
something is wrong with my problem so
you know either way you know check
quickly what you've done and if you can
spine a mistake then you know just move
ahead to the next problem
yes which one this one oh yeah I mean if
you can do it you know if you know how
to do it whichever thing is fair I mean
generally speaking you know give enough
evidence that you found the solution by
yourself not like you know you know it
didn't somehow come to you by magic but
yeah I mean if you know how to integrate
this without doing the substitution
that's absolutely fine by me
interests you know sure enough work
general will always show enough work
that we see that you know you know what
you are doing okay now another thing
we've seen with double integrals is how
to do more complicated changes of
variables
so you know when you want to replace X&Y
by some variables U and V given by some
formulas in terms of x and y so you need
to remember basically how to do them so
you need to remember that the method
consists of three steps so one is you
have to find the Jacobian and you can
choose to do either this Jacobian of the
inverse one depending on what's easiest
given what you're given you know you
don't have to worry about solving for
things we have a way around just compute
one of these jacobians and when the hole
is that dudv is absolute value of the
Jacobian DX dy so that takes care of DX
dy how to convert that into the U DV the
second thing to know is that well you
need to of course substitute any X and
Y's in the integrand to convert them to
use and Vees so that you have you know a
valid integrand involving only U and V
and then the last part is setting up the
bounds
and you've seen that probably you've
seen on psets and an example within
lecture but this can be complicated but
now in real life you know you do
basically to simplify the integrals so
probably the one that will be there on
Thursday you know it does program about
that on Thursday it will be a situation
where the bounds that you get after
changing variables are reasonably easy
okay I'm not saying that there will be
completely obvious necessarily but it
will be a fairly easy situation so the
general method is you look at your
region R and you know it might have
various sides then on each side you ask
yourself what do I know about x and y
and how to convert that in terms of U
and V and maybe you will find that you
know the equation might be just u equals
0 for example or u equals V or something
like that and then it's up to you to
decide what you want to do but maybe the
easiest usually is to draw a new picture
in terms of U and V coordinates of what
your engine will look like in the new
coordinates and it might be that it will
be actually much easier it should be
easier looking than what you started
with ok so that's the general idea
there's one change of variable problem
and each other to practice exams to give
you a feeling for you know what's
realistic the one the problem that's on
practice exam maybe actually is on the
hot side of things because it's you know
a question it's kind of hidden in a way
so if you look at column six you might
find that it's not telling you very
clearly what you have to do that's
because it's well it was meant to be the
hardest problem on that test
but once you've reduced it to an actual
change of variables problem I expect you
to be able to know how to do it and on
practice exam why a there's also like I
think it's problem five on the other
practice exam and that one is actually
pretty standard and straightforward
okay time to move on sorry so we've also
seen about line integrals
okay so line integrals so the main thing
to know about them so the line integral
for work which is 19 all of f dot dr so
let's say that your vector field has
components m and n so the line integral
for work becomes in coordinates integral
of M DX plus n dy while we've also seen
line integral for flux so line integral
of F dot NDS becomes the integral along
c of just to make sure that I gave it to
you correctly so remember that I don't
want to make a mistake in front of you
never know so TDS is d X comma dy and
the normal vector
so it's you know TDS goes along the
curve NDS goes clockwise perpendicular
to the curve so it's going to be well
it's going to be D Y and negative DX so
you will be integrating negative n DX
plus M dy
okay see if you are blanking and don't
remember the signs then you can just go
this picture and make sure that you get
it right so you should know a little bit
about you know geometric interpretation
and how to see easily that it's going to
be zero in some cases but mostly you
should know how to compute you know set
up and compute these things so what do
we do when we are here well here we have
both X and Y's together but we want to
because it's the line integral that's
the only one variable so the important
thing to know is we want to reduce
everything to a single parameter okay so
the evaluation method is always by
videos by reducing to a single parameter
for example you know maybe x and y are
both functions of some variable T and
then express everything in terms of some
integral of some quantity involving T DT
could be that you will just express
everything in terms of X so in terms of
Y or in terms of some angle or something
so to you to choose how to parameterize
things and then when you're there it's a
usual one variable integral with a
single variable in there okay so that's
the general method of calculation but
we've seen a shortcut for work when we
can show that the field is the gradient
of a potential so one thing to know is
if the curl of F which is an X minus my
happens to be zero well and now I can
say and the domain is simply connected
or if you want if a field is defined
everywhere
then f is actually a gradient field so
that means just to make it more concrete
that means we can find a function little
F called the potential such that it's
derivative respect to X is M and the
derivative respect to Y is M we can
solve these two conditions for the same
function f simultaneously and how do we
find this function little F okay so
that's the same as saying that the field
big f is the gradient of little F and
how do we find this function little F
well we've seen two methods one of them
involves computing a line integral from
the origin to a point in the plane by
going first along the x axis then
vertically the other method was to first
figure out what this one tells us by
integrating it with respect to X and
then we differentiate our answer with
respect to Y and we compare with that to
get the complete answer okay so why is
that relevant well first of all it's
relevant in physics but it's also
relevant just to you know calculation of
line integrals because we've seen the
fundamental theorem of calculus for line
integrals which says if we are
integrating a gradient field and we know
what the potential is then we just have
to well the line integral is just the
change in value of the potential okay so
we take the value of a potential at the
starting point so we take value
potential at the endpoint minus we value
at the starting point and that will give
us the line integral so important this
is only for work there's no statement
like that for flux okay so don't you
know don't try to apply this in the
modern world flux when usually you'll
see but it you know if you look at the
practice exams you'll see it's pretty
clear that there's one problem in which
you're supposed to do things this way
it's kind of a dead giveaway but it's
probably
not too bad okay and the other thing
we've seen so I mentioned it in the
beginning but let me mention it again
to conclude things greens theorem
lets us compute line integral lets us
forget you know evaluate fine so I find
the value of a line integral around the
closed curve by reducing it to a double
integral so the one for work says since
this and you should remember in there so
C is a closed curve that goes
counterclockwise and our is the region
inside so the way you would you know if
you had to compute both sides slightly
you would do them in extremely different
ways all right this one is a line
integral so you use the method they
explained here namely you express x and
y in terms of a single variable you know
say that you live in the circle I want
to see a theta I don't want to see an R
is not a variable here on the circle
this one is a double integral so if
you're doing it say on a disk you would
have both R and theta if you're using
polar coordinates we would have both x
and y here you have two variables of
integration here you should have only
one after you parameterize the curve and
you know the fact that it stays curl f
I mean curl F is just an X minus M Y is
just any you know it's just like any
function of x and y if I felt that we
called it curl f doesn't change how you
compute it you know you have first to
compute the curl of F let's say you find
I don't know XY minus x squared well it
becomes just the usual double integral
of the usual function XY minus x squared
there's nothing special to it because it
circle and the other one is the
counterpart of flux
so it says bass and remember this is MX
plus NY
I mean what's important about these
statements is not only remember you know
if you just know this formula by heart
you're still in trouble because you need
to know what actually the symbols in
here mean so you should remember you
know what is this line integral and
what's the divergence of a field so you
know just something to remember and so I
guess I'll let you you know figure out
practice problems because it's time but
I think that's basically the list of all
we've seen and well that should be it